hello hello Dave and Chad I wonder if
you could take us back to the beginning
of this project were you all lifelong
fans of Oscar and Big Bird or was this a
project that you know came about from an
interest in exploring the Sesame Street
world no it's actually a project that
started with with an internship of
course Chad and I grew up on Sesame
and we're always big fans of the show
and then as we decided to sort of follow
our paths into the industry I wanted to
go to work up Sesame because it's such
an amazing place to be and I had this
internship in their home Baylor
Department wasn't anywhere close to the
to the production or to the set and
several years later I was telling a
friend about it and she said that she
happened to know Caroll Spinney and I
didn't know anything about Carol or who
he was and she explained that he was Big
Bird and Oscar since 1969 in China I had
been working at a dock at that time and
he said this should really be our next
film and thankfully Carol said yes with
Sesame I you know I just grew up
watching it loving it and well it was
kind of funny is that I didn't realize
how much I'm an impact it had on me
until we were making this movie because
going through all the archival footage
and the behind the scenes stuff
something you would watch something a
little segment you know in your research
and all of a sudden like brought back
like that so like being six years old
you know with your mom watching the show
and that was just really powerful so I
had forgotten how much it meant to me
until we made this movie Carol could you
take us back to the moment where Chad
and Dave came up to you what was your
thought when they had approached you
well they they contacted Sesame Street
Elland Lois Ellen Lewis and she's a door
she's a good friend but anyway she she
said that there was some young fellows
who have a
do film company that would like to do a
film about you and I said really me I
don't I don't I didn't think it would be
worth making a movie of me but I said
well sure we'll come down talk to them
and we talked to the more impressed with
them and they certainly sounded like
they know what they're doing they lent
us a film that they produced already
it's terrific and that was brownstones
in red dirt and so we chatted with him a
while and I thought that if anybody does
it they certainly would convinced us
they had their sensitive guys they do
the good job and I'm just amazed at what
they created but I think we we had a
huge amount of archives oh did we yeah
in that meeting Deb was also there and
she kind of dropped the bomb that you
know I'm not a professional she said but
I've pretty much recorded everything
we've ever done and so Dave and I were
like are gonna be amazing and also in
that meeting I don't know if you
remember but we were talking about
gluten allergies oh yes then you pulled
out Oscar and Oscar went boring and I
was like totally surreal when you met
Carole did you have any idea of the
backstory of what you were about to
explore no we had read you know some
articles about Carole some profiles and
things like that but all we really knew
was that when he first moved to New York
he didn't like it at the time I think
you were 76 like I got 76 he's
definitely gonna retire so this film is
gonna be about probably his last year
and that's what it was others film is
gonna be about the last year of an
American icon and then like the first
thing he said in that meeting was yeah
I'm not gonna retire I want to do this
for like 50 years
so like alright let's let's figure out
what this film is gonna be about
luckily then Deb dropped the bomb I
videotaped everything we've ever done
okay that's gonna be pretty great and
you're also witnessing something rare
which is Carol and Deborah not usually
this far apart physically it was very
obvious that it was a it was going to be
a love story and said that was something
that we knew right away and then
obviously I chose reference once that
footage came to our doorstep we we had
the material to make that film about the
two of them in their love well let's
talk about that footage how many hours
did Deb shoot it was probably over 500
hours of stuff that and you have way
more than that too that was just the
stuff you dropped off but what was kind
of funny to started out like on film so
you had these like very succinct clips
you know and like like fall that bird
right was all film and everything was a
golden nugget and then VHA VHS hit and
then it would be like four hours of
driving through New Zealand you know but
you we would always watch every minute
of it because then you never knew when
it was gonna cut and there would be
these little gems of like we use it in
the film of Carol running and falling
down a hill and rolling kind of goofy
and Deb you laughing and it's so sweet
you know so yeah it was probably like
500 hours and we went to watched every
yeah and transcribed it yeah and
transcribed it probably work took four
and a half years well at that four and a
half years yeah at the end there was a
stack of five tapes sitting on our edit
just like staring at us like you have to
go through us and we were like we're not
going to we've done enough and but we
end up going through them and like big
bird in the limousine that's in the
movie some of the symphony stuff that
was all from the very last tape that we
went through Carol did you share in
their exploration of your past no I
don't even know what time they live in I
know that Dave mattina lives in this
town with his parents due to not with my
parents let me just clarify you you had
said though watching the movie you you
two are seeing stuff that you had
forgotten you even shot and saw all
right yeah well many times we've come
back from a trip and we never get around
to watching the movie so much of the
film we'd never seen so it was kind of
fun for us to watch the movie as well as
kind of strange to see yourself up on
the screen because I've made about sixty
years ago I had my first TV show which
was in Vegas a page of all of $10 a week
and I would have done it for free
in 1955 television was only about seven
or eight years old and so I was thrilled
I was 21 and the fact that I could get
into the deal
I mean television I didn't even have a
monitor I couldn't see what I was doing
it must have been just terrible
but at least he got me the $10 a week
which was a lot more better money than
you'd think in today's money would
barely buy you a magazine and a and a
candy bar but back then I think ten
dollars would be equivalent of more like
$40 so between the TV show and
illustrating I'm an illustrator all
those pictures are mine except for the
animation that was done and but they're
friends of theirs one of the wasn't just
real quick the thing about his archival
footage it's really fascinating for a
roomful of creative people it wasn't
just like they would be like oh there's
Deb and she's walking on the beach or
whatever they would shoot like coverage
and cutaways so they would set the
camera on a tripod and the two of them
were then get in the car and drive off
of the distance past the horizon and
then they'd cut come back pick up the
camera and so it's like it was always
still there it was it was really a
godsend for us you would never could
have imagined that these eight
millimeter movies which my friend
fabulous Folger and I he had a vest but
I had a Lambretta which was a little
fancier version of the Vespa we drove
from central Germany all the way to Rome
and but I had an eight millimeter Bell
on Howell
which I'd bought when I was 20 when I
could for a federal refund and I always
want to get into movies and so I started
making my own they weren't very good I
suppose but I never thought and either
would be up on the big screen and
they're very sharp focus you notice
because the negative of on 8 millimeter
is just over a quarter inch wide so when
you blow that up on a 60-foot screen
it's quite soft image but it seemed
pretty good for for our panel stops
great yeah I would love the tricks you
would do he'd stand in front of a statue
and then you would cut and then you'd be
gone in the statue would be there there
are a lot of those kind of fun tricks
yes
around but I bought the little Kodak
book tricks you can do with your movie
camera I think we should bring in our
special guest tonight which is I believe
the second iteration of one of Carol's
great great creations what was it like
when you first encountered this creation
what did you feel like this was the in
two big bird or an essential component
the dark side well I didn't really know
Oscar till I started playing him because
he didn't exist before this it was an
idea that Jim Henson had got from a
restaurant over on the east on Third
Avenue called
Oscars seafood restaurant and Oscar pops
up a lot around here I think the name
the word so and there was a very
irritable
jimson there's a there's a a waiter that
I want you to meet he's very grouchy and
that's where I got the idea that we
should make a grouch because some
grouches can be quite humorous and he
was done he was actually a probably a
fairly pleasant Grouch
I think grouches enjoy being grouchy I
know I do
so I I didn't I knew one eye was called
my father he was alone it was
complicated because I really he would
like my older brother Donald Donald was
mostly awful to me but what's a while
he'd be nice I'd be grateful so
therefore I was so I loved him all over
again and so didn't your dad he would go
around supermarkets right and hand out
yeah it's funny he'd lived to be almost
91 and when he hated my mom lived to she
was almost she was she died just just
exactly 30 days after he did and I found
a little note she had written dear Beth
I don't know who Beth was so I didn't
send it to her
my dearest darling has died and now I'm
going to go join him goodbye
beg my mama's Margaret and she has to be
called peg so that so I PR department
which of which is headed now by Ellen
who helped get this film going
she gave a big stack of coloured
postcards of Big Bird to me so I gave a
stack to my father had pre signed them
big bird so he would take them to the
supermarket and he would see a little
tot writing in a food cart you know he
could put their little feet through and
he'd go over and say we're big birds
mommy and daddy and here they were
how much 90 it is in there humans and
they'd say another kid I don't the kid
would be look confused but quite
delighted to have this colorful card to
hand it them with their friend Big Bird
on it and so he would finally he said I
need some more bad about all about but
that was one of his greatest old-time
old age things he did he wasn't too
active I am now 81 and heading that
direction but I hope to stay a little
more active than he did you thank you
and thank you Oscar y'all never thank a
grouch and I was I was bored the whole
time
were you really oh yeah
thank you I have once one thing I'd like
to say to you very fine people have a
rotten day